The number that belongs here is 23. So, how did I figure that out? Well, one way
to check if the solution is correct is by writing this equation, and then
substituting in values for d and for n, and seeing if they match our table. We
know that,= after 3 days, for example, 69 wiper sets have been produced. So,
that means that if we take d and we replace it with 3, we should get that n
equals 69. And sure enough, 23 times 3 is 69. That checks off their table. So,
we can see that our equation fits the situation that we were trying to make it
fit. You could do a similar thing with any of the other sets of entries on this
table. When you plug in a number for d, you should end up with a corresponding
number for n when you simplify. But checking if a solution is correct is pretty
different from creating the solution yourself. So, how did we come up with these
mathematical descriptions, these equations on our own? That's what the next few
lessons are going to be about.